la question en fait la question isabelle
déjà sache que tu es la pitié ma
chronique est préféré à l'aim les
personnes âgées
c'est pour ça aussi que j'aimerais te
poser cette question mon âge jamais ce
nom là la dernière fois il ya eu la
polémique la grosse polémique y avait
autour d'eux mais neil la ferme enel et
du coup c'est vrai que tu sais la
polémique qui a vu derrière sur les
propos que tu as tenu qu'ils ont été
bons perdants bien ou alors ils avaient
l'avait dit à ce moment là pour que les
téléspectateurs tune qui nous rejoignent
vous avez dit vous avez eu cette phrase
voilà on en a reparlé qui était
maladroite et blé vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous même vous avez dit elle a
chanté en arabe c'est pas le moment les
temps qui étaient nécessaires et pour le
coup j'ai pu comprendre ce même mois
derrière la réaction première que j'ai
vu mais qu'est ce qu'elle dit pas mes
jambes je vais j'essaie 3 comment je
comprenais pas je dis cela veut dire
enfin pourquoi par les temps qui courent
et puis parce que en plus je peux tu te
rassure moi tu as dit la chanson arabe
ça me gêne pas le vol ça me gêne pas
mais par les temps qui courent donc j'ai
pas compris d'un côté c'est ça ne gênait
pas mais d'un côté par les temps qui
courent donc c'est juste avant les
qualifications alors que je voulais en
fait savoir si tu pouvais justement
éclaircir parce que du coup avec tous
les débats qui a vu sur pour le coup
elle n'a jamais réussi à finir à 2
s'explique everett a raison ça non et du
coup à chaque fois on attendait
l'explication mais moi je suis dit zut
c'est aujourd'hui elle a pas dit du tout
elle a arrêté le travail et dise en
cause de ça a été tellement pas bien dit
jean charest
elle a quatre enfants alors que les
groupes
merci d'être là isabelle répondait sans
détour hellmuth vous regarde on est
prêts lorsque sur cette femme de tout
alors je redis que j'avais dit que le
voile ne me gênait pas et moi je ne
demande pas l'éviction contrairement à
ce qu'elle dit télérama et ce qu'a
répété de télérama donc ça c'est
totalement faux en revanche c'est vrai
si j'avais regardé l'émission en direct
j'aurais vu une jeune femme qui chante
très très bien déconner tu manges aurait
même été incapable d'évaluer dans quelle
langue elle chantait le lendemain moi je
les visionner en replay au moment de
toute la polémique où il y avait déjà
oui elle a ajouté un couplet qui
peut-être pas complètement neutre et
puis elle est proche des familles dé sa
famille relativement radicaliser pour
moi y avait déjà cette polémique quand
je les ai vus
donc je ne l'ait pas vu sereinement je
l' ai vu avec déjà tout le magma qui
avait autour et donc c'est vrai
maintenant on est en direct ce que ne
sont pas toutes les autres émissions
dites polémique
et c'est vrai que je me suis entendu
dire ça et moi même le syli merde
pourquoi je dis ça mais c'était nice été
dit et dit maintenant avec les réseaux
sociaux tu mets la merde dans le ventilo
et puis c'est ça tu reviens dans la
tronche était couvert mais ça va
doit être remercié leurs actes alex
émond c'est un gros bisou à ton mari etc
qui à côté tottenham ensemble merci à
tous quel taux pas gros bisous jean
bouin phil hellmuth est ce que tu es
convaincu de la réponse d'isabelle à 100
% à 100 %
apparemment il est convaincu d'isabelle
allemagne pour vous non on va vous non
il aplatit et moi je suis pas je suis
pas de détecteur de phase i et pas deux